hey youtubers is Charlie welcome back to
my season 4 countdown during my Game of
Thrones movie video this past weekend I
asked you to submit all your questions
about potential movies stories as well
as the back end of the series so I
picked 10 of them to answer in this
video with one bonus question if you're
finding me for the first time and you're
all like WTF countdown I'm just doing
special countdown videos to the season 4
premiere once it gets here I'll be doing
regular weekly videos just like I do for
Walking Dead I'll even be doing a weekly
giveaway so it's gonna be a ton of fun
be sure to subscribe to get everything
also feel free to suggest any topics you
want for bonus videos but here we go
careful for potential spoilers for
season 4 most of the stuff we're gonna
be talking about is prequel material
though stuff for the movies so it
shouldn't be too bad but question number
one comes from Lady Cersei I'm afraid of
you how much will Jaime's perspective
differ from the books just because the
timeline is messed up a little so yeah
in the books Jaime doesn't get back to
King's Landing till much later than
where we are on the show right now
meaning he's going to be there to
witness some stuff in all honesty I
think the way they've been developing
all the characters that are at King's
Landing I don't think his character will
act or feel any different than he did in
the books there will be a few new scenes
things that didn't happen exactly in the
books but only for continuity with the
story that the show is telling so really
short answer Jaime is gonna be the same
as he was in the books his character arc
won't change which I am really happy
about because he's gonna be one of my
new favorite characters in season 4 my
favorites tend to change from season to
season question number two Netta de Toro
asks how many movies do you think they
could get from the dance of the Dragons
story so for those who don't know the
dance of the Dragons is a Targaryen
Civil War that happened many many years
before current events in the show I
think they could totally turn that into
a Lord of the Rings you know Hobbit
style trilogy that seems to be the style
nowadays with these huge epic
adaptations turned what would normally
be one movie into three movies not that
I would complain if they did that it
would mean an extra four to five years
of Game of Thrones movies assuming they
start with one trilogy I think if they
do end up doing a movie though they will
start with the current characters in the
show just to give george RR martin time
to finish stream of spring they'll just
wrap
events and whatever the end of the
series is question number three she have
shibir asks what do you think the
upcoming game of Thrones game will be
about so if you're talking about the
telltale games one it's gonna be about
the current characters on the show
they'll probably expand on events and
just give us a chance to see battles and
places that don't appear in the books or
events that are only mentioned briefly
it's possible that they could also do a
prequel story in a future season tell
tells Walking Dead game actually use the
different characters in the TV series
but either way they're a great company
and I'll be making gameplay videos
whenever it comes it's not coming till
December this year which is a long way
off but I will try and get my hands on a
pre-release copy question number four
Alex Garcia asks what are the chances of
seeing a game of Thrones Robert's
rebellion series that would fill in the
gaps that Jon Snow's birth so I think
it's more likely that they would tell
that story in a flashback I think any
movie they did would just really tie up
whatever they didn't have time to do
during the final season or set up a
spin-off franchise like Duncan egg I do
think that Jon Snow will find out who
his true mother and father are before
the series is over whether or not he
solves it himself or someone else tells
them question number five Matthew bloch
asks do you think that the show will
start hinting at big events that
happened in the novel's yet so I assume
you're talking about if the show passes
the novel's Martin says that he thinks
that he's got through season five before
that happens by which time he'll have
finished wins a winner which gives him
another two seasons it's really not
until we get to season 7 I think that
he's in trouble it's way too soon to
tell but remember Martin told David
Benioff and DB Weiss what the ending was
in case that happened they just need to
know because they're already planning
season five and they don't want to kill
a character that's potentially really
important later down the line and it
helps them to know where everyone needs
to be you know going into the final
seasons so short answer yes the show
will pass the books but not for a couple
years
question number six Christina Barton
asks how do you put all the info in your
videos so thank you for asking about how
I make my videos typically I just do a
lot of reading normally I already have
an idea of what I want to say and I just
do research in the books and forums to
get facts straight it's not super
complicated but if I'm making a really
long video with a lot of information it
takes forever to collect all those facts
so sometimes it can take a long time
and I don't read from a teleprompter or
anything but I do write down everything
that I want to say just so I have
something to refer back to like some
notes and it really helps when I try to
make subtitles later question number
seven formal gab boom asks has there
been anything written about the doom of
Valyria yes the book is called a world
of Ice and Fire but it's not being
released till October of this year you
can totally read more about ancient
Valyria in that I'll be sure to do a
review whatever it does come out but
Mardon is also writing a really cool
book called fire and blood it's gonna be
a complete history of House Targaryen
which existed in old Valyria but that
book won't be written till after a dream
of spring so it's gonna be a long time
question number eight bang maid asks did
George our Martin indicate whether the
movies would be continued under the
supervision of Benioff and Weiss no he
didn't say anything about that and to be
clear they just reappear contract with
HBO for season five which means that
it's possible but not likely that they
could leave the show before it's over I
don't think that's gonna happen though
it's been so successful under them that
there's no reason for them to leave
unless HBO refuses to pay them more
money question number nine Chris B asks
which two characters would you most like
to see meet each other so I don't have
to but I do have three and it's Daenerys
Jon Snow in Tyrion my own personal dream
team for the three heads of the Dragon
it's totally possible that that's not
the way that prophecy is going to go
down but tyrion studies a lot of dragon
lore so I think he'll be associated with
them at some point whether or not he
gets to ride one though that remains to
be seen
question number 10 candor and - asks how
does one become a greenseer so good
question so one in every 1,000 people in
the world is born a warg or a
skin-changer and one in every thousand
of those people is born a greenseer so
technically you're born but it's super
super rare on the show the three-eyed
Raven is the only green seer in the
world bran is supposed to be the next
one that's why it's so easy for him to
warg into people like Hodor
normal skin changers cannot do that
based on the images in the trailer we're
gonna see a lot of that greenseer story
play out who else was disappointed
though whenever the eyes on that
weirwood did not open and one last bonus
question this is a fun
Melanie Rojas asks do you subscribe to
the R + L theory of Jon Snow's parents
so I do yes mostly because it logically
lines up with the timeline of Robert's
rebellion in everything that we know
about the characters involved plus it
would put Jon Snow in a very specific
place going into the big you know final
battle with the great other than the
army of the White Walkers when I say
that what I mean is it would validate a
lot of the Ozora hi and three heads of
the Dragon theories it would also get
him tied up in ancient blood magic which
just sounds so awesome don't you just
feel like his character would be ten
times more interesting if that R + L
theory is true it really is the most
logical given the facts that we have
based on what they've said in interviews
DB Weiss and David Benioff were able to
guess it immediately after reading those
first four books so it's not a super
mystery anyone is welcome to pose
alternate theories though but thank you
so much for submitting your questions
this is a lot of fun my next countdown
video will probably be my top 10 moments
from season 3 but feel free to suggest a
bonus topic in the comments below right
now click here to get my dragon history
video and click here to get the rest of
my season 4 countdown videos thank you
so much for watching I'll see you guys
tomorrow high fives
you